She-Hulk fans, rejoice: the rumor mill may
have given us a clue as to when Jennifer Walters
will finally appear the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Sources close to Cosmic Book News have indicated
that Marvel may be looking at the third solo
Spider-Man film to introduce the character
and while this is little more than speculation
for now, there are a couple of factors working
in the rumor's favour.
First, there's an offhand remark that Spider-Man:
Far From Home star Tom Holland made a couple
months back in an interview with Fandom.
Holland was bandying about the names of several
interesting characters whom he'd like to one
day see in the MCU, from Nick Fury, Jr. to
Riri Williams, also known as Ironheart.
But in the middle of all this, Holland took
time out to explain that he'd love to see
Spidey team up with Mark Ruffalo's Hulk in
a future adventure.
Holland explained:
"[Hulk] is so funny, and they're both science
geeks."
And while Jennifer Walters isn't quite the
same character as Bruce Banner, an appearance
by Hulk in Spider-Man 3 could easily set up
the introduction of Walters, who in the comics
is Banner's cousin.
"Best of both worlds."
More interesting, however, is the alleged
plot that Marvel is cooking up for the third
solo Spidey outing.
Although you'll need to take this with a healthy
dose of salt, Cosmic Book News reports that
YouTuber TVO has the skinny straight from
inside sources that the plot of Marvel's third
Spider-Man flick will follow directly from
Far From Home's mid-credits sequence, in which
blowhard vlogger J. Jonah Jameson publicly
reveals doctored footage making it appear
as if Spidey, not Mysterio, had been to blame
for the staged elemental attacks on various
European locales.
In fact, this footage even puts Spidey on
the hook for straight-up killing Mysterio
and the villain, with his supposed dying breath,
reveals the web-slinger's secret identity
to the world.
According to TVO's sources, the third flick
will see Peter Parker attempting to clear
his name through the proper channels, that
is, the legal system.
Apparently, the idea was put forth that acting
as Parker's defense attorney would be none
other than Matt Murdock, also known as Daredevil,
a situation for which there is ample precedent
in the comics.
"And I'm a Catholic - I have a soft spot for hopeless
causes."
Unfortunately, that plot would be tricky to
pull off.
As part of the deal struck between Netflix
and Marvel, reportedly none of the characters
who appeared in the streamer's now-defunct
slate of Marvel series are eligible for use
in the MCU until two full years after each
respective series' cancellation.
That means that Marvel Studios would have
to wait for a while before bringing Murdock
into play in any capacity.
Rather than deal with the possibility of having
to adjust the timetable for production on
the next Spidey flick, Marvel's brain trust
simply defaulted to the next most well-known
attorney in all of Marvel lore Walters.
In the comics, hotshot lawyer Jennifer Walters
is shot and seriously injured by a vengeful
gangster while in town for a visit.
She receives a blood transfusion from dear
cousin Bruce, leading to Walters becoming
the savage She-Hulk.
The character has gone through quite an evolution
since she first debuted; as she retains her
intellect and personality post-transformation,
she even eventually decides to just remain
Hulked out permanently, even in the course
of her day job as a defense lawyer.
Although TVO's sources didn't let on as to
whether Walters would appear in her She-Hulk
persona during the film, there's something
to be said for the idea of Parker being represented
in court by a giant, green superhero lawyer.
At any rate, it's important to reiterate that
this is an unverified rumor.
Still, it would be a pretty cool way to introduce
Walters into an MCU that could sorely use
a new Hulk especially now that Banner is probably
undergoing intensive physical therapy after
that whole Infinity Gauntlet thing went down.
That looked like it hurt.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.